this train heels off the warm-up in
honor of his dearly departed friend Kobe
Bryant he will start the game wearing
uniform number 8 that's a great
representation Kobe Bryant that's paying
homage way to go through and the two
teams and the referees have agreed to
two other things that will show you here
in just a second to honor Kobe as Rodney
Mott comes to the center jump circle
walks in red wizards of blue and now
trey is going to hang out of the
basketball and in honor of number eight
he is going to take an 8 second
backcourt violation and now the Wizards
to show their honor and appreciation
Washington is going to impound the
basketball and they will take a
24-second violation
neither locker room was available to the
media prior to tonight's game and
neither team came out then went through
their normal kind of individual routines
DJ and it wasn't until about 10 minutes
before the lights went down for the
national anthem that the teams came out
on the floor and went through a brief
warm-up so players like the rest of this
trying to process this is this will be a
moment that both teams will take part in
to honor
[Applause]
Kobe Bryant and they will take the 24
set shot clock violation
[Applause]
[Applause]
and what a great honor oh we had such an
impact on this game Ricky Rubio is going
to take an eight-second violation to
represent number eight that Kobe or
early in his career this is just a true
testament of how tremendous Kobe was as
a player but also the impact that he had
on these guys out here on the floor he
was a basketball player you all have
your impact older guys were an impact
for me these guys out here today's games
the guys that they follow were MJ at the
end of his career but Kobe for most of
his career that is the one guy that they
fell in love with the game of basketball
by watching so what a tremendous honor
for both of these teams to execute this
and of course just a handful of players
for both these teams who were fortunate
enough to replied I'm on my way into the
arena
I thought of billed gallo
Dallow is the legendary sports
cartoonist that when Thurman Munson
passed away the next day he had a
unbelievably touching cartoon and it was
his two characters that he had basement
Bertha and yucky and the cartoon red
basement Bertha saying now yucky I just
don't feel like playing ball today and
she was crying and that's the way I
think a lot of us feel here tonight just
don't feel like broadcasting I know a
lot of the players mmm excuse me I don't
feel like playing it's just a sad sad
day yeah you're right Mike it was like a
shot man to you players these players
don't know Michael
Templeton
[Applause]
and the chance of Kobe Bryant
we're here now Madison Square Garden
there is a moment of silence
before the game
and after the moment of silence see is a
Chan of Kobe holding
many kobe jerseys and the Toronto
Raptors Bennett dribble it up there's a
24-second shot clock and of course Kobe
Bryant wore number 24 and I wonder if
that is what is happening in in honor of
him 24-second shot clock expires
[Applause]
and the job don't worry we'll do the
same
24-second shot clock of course Kobe
Wyatt
over 24
[Applause]
recognize that we chanted Kobe
basketball fans
a tragedy has befallen the world of
basketball earlier today at the age of
41 Kobe Bryant was killed in a
helicopter crash in 20 seasons with the
Lakers Kobe was a 17 time all-star
two-time NBA Finals MVP two-time Olympic
gold medalist and five-time NBA champion
the NBA and the game of basketball will
mourn this loss together please join us
in a moment of silence for Kobe Bryant
rest in peace Mamba
damian lillard and we're going to see
both teams do what we've seen all day
long here Quinn a 24-second shot clock
violation in honor of Kobe Bryant yeah
it's pretty good I mean what all of the
league is he's basically done a
24-second violation as many of you know
that was his number some had done the
eight-second violation to get it across
half court because that was his number
but in great appreciation for Kobe
Bryant and all he did for the league and
and and everybody in the NBA and Quinn
you made your comments I'm looking here
at Carmelo Anthony who was his teammate
and friend on USA basketball Pinkertons
of our table and now it's an
eight-second violation that the Pacers
take the two numbers at Kobe Bryant wore
24 and 8 and there's per melon I'm
looking at Camello he's having a hard
time as a mine yeah